the summit was about renewing our
relationship based on a clear timetable
for action migration of the primary
reason why we all meet match today let
me state clearly that we do not expect
anyone to guard our border for us that
can and should only be done by Europeans
but we expect a major step towards
changing the rules of the game when it
comes to stemming the migration flow
that is coming to the you via turkey
turkey remains a key strategic partner
for Europe but also a candidate country
of the you oh no there won't be a
solution of the migration crisis without
close cooperation between the European
Union and Turkey turkey is accommodating
over 2 million refugees it is doing that
in an admirable fashion in many respects
and we would like to support turkey in
the continuation of this effort we are
prepared to make available a sum of
three billion euros on this 3 billion
euro is not given to Turkey it is given
to Syrian refugees we have realized our
accession process we have agreed to have
an integrated strategy against all
instabilities in the neighborhood of
Europe and also to work together
shoulder to shoulder regarding the
refugee crisis with today's decision
both sides have committed to step up the
tempo on these accessions talks with a
view to making progress but the
benchmarks and standards will remain the
same